Speaker 1: I want to talk about 2024 and 2024
as possible Republican contenders.
I'm not talking about Donald Trump here.
Donald Trump is running, at least for now,
unless he drops out.
I'm talking about the other possible contenders
in Fox Business.
And actually Fox News in general has regularly
been putting up images like the one we're
putting up now.
This one is called possible Republican candidates
in 2024.
And indeed, Donald Trump isn't on that list
because Trump is not a possible candidate.
He is a candidate.
The folks listed include former Vice President
Mike Pence, current Florida Governor Ron DeSantis.
Virginia Governor Glenn Youngkin.
Larry Hogan.
Asa Hutchinson.
Senator Tim Scott, Mike Pompeo, Nikki Haley
and Chris Christie.
And what's really interesting about this list
is that it's a really scary list.
And I thought, let's just talk a little bit
about the people that are sort of considered
contenders to be Republican presidential nominee,
at least hypothetically, and think through
how extreme the party has gotten.
At the end of the segment, I'll tell you who
would be my choice if I wanted to to to limit
damage to the country.
And I'll tell you in a moment, you've got
Mike Pence.
Mike Pence, wildly against abortion, skeptical
about climate change, has a history of opposing
LGBT rights, wants to build that wall with
Mexico, has been against Obamacare, never
mind stronger health care programs than Obamacare.
Seems very interested in religion more and
more officially playing a role in civil government
and also just on a personal level is kind
of a kind of a moron in the sense that even
though Trump's supporters were calling for
him to be hanged, he still doesn't totally
denounce Trump, although he kind of has.
And he said, I think we'll have better candidates
or whatever.
It's just a guy who is both spineless and
has some of the worse political views.
That's one alternative to Trump for the Republican
Party.
Okay, it's pretty bad.
Then you've got Ron DeSantis.
Ron DeSantis, whose record as Florida governor
is one of regularly signing into law bills
that restrict abortion in Florida, loves restricting
abortion, regularly weakens gun laws in Florida
at every opportunity supported repealing the
Affordable Care Act, has a horrible environmental
record in Florida, loves fossil fuels, opportunities
to use more fossil fuels and make it easier
to use fossil fuels.
DeSantis loves it, and in addition to that,
DeSantis is arguably more competent than Trump
and as a result, could be extraordinarily
more dangerous if he became the president
of the United States.
Then you've got arguably one of the slightly
less extreme people on the list, Larry Hogan.
But you look at his record and it's horrifying
against abortion, as most of these people
are against the Affordable Care Act tried
to repeal the Affordable Care Act, supports
the oil and gas industry backwards, just totally
backwards.
And we're supposed to see him as less extreme
to pick a senator.
Tim Scott from South Carolina.
Tim Scott against abortion, wants to restrict
access to abortion, is against any gun safety
regulations.
Supports every tax cut that's proposed.
Skeptical about climate science, even though
he doesn't actually know anything about it.
So I could go on and on and on.
It's an insane list of people.
Now, if I look at the list and you said to
me, David, and this is something that probably
would bring tears to your eyes if you came
to and said, David, it's going to be one of
the people on this list.
Tears, if you knew it was going to be one
of these people who defeat the Democrat.
Who would you choose?
The to me, it seems clear that it's Chris
Christie.
And I'm glad to hear from other people and
see your opinions.
But when I look at this list, Pence, DeSantis,
Youngkin, Hogan Hutchinson, Scott Pompeo,
Haley, Christie and then Trump, who has already
declared to me, it's Chris Christie.
Chris Christie is a smart guy in a way that
a lot of these other people aren't.
Maybe DeSantis, but but you know, like Pence
and Yang.
Christie is a smart guy, former prosecutor,
more moderate socially to some degree because
of his experience as governor.
And a Northeastern governor understands compromise
and working across the aisle in a way that
some of these other people do.
Now, I know people will write to me and say,
David Christie's insane.
What are you talking about?
Remember?
It's if one of these people was going to be
the next president.
I think I'm choosing Chris Christie.
And I'm interested to hear from others.
But it's shaping up to be a pretty scary list.
Now, fortunately or unfortunately, I don't
know.
You know, names like Don Junior are sometimes
thrown around.
They're not showing up on this list, at least
not yet.
And I think we should probably be happy about
that.